et la bologne
et il y a des nuits qui ne mami que d'autres
les nuits qui viennent si tu es tu es le
football combien de fois vont-ils m'avoir
enlevés étaient trois ou quatre
jours si je n'obtenais pas ce que beaucoup voulaient
les choses que nous souffrons et un sac d'enseignement
d'ici dans le pantalon une machette m'a dit
que parce que la plupart des gens aiment
J'ai dû descendre dans la tête
les choses
et le moment et il le met à chaque fois
l'auditorium de la constitution
[Applaudissements]
c'est le déjeuner
Je viens menacer tes jours déclare que
il dort l'autre jour
comme ça avec un couteau c'est ici moyen
ils m'ont donné plus grand
le travail des 13 ans j'ai 53 ans
travail des 13 ans plus enfants oui
nous avons passé ceux de cain avec nos
père génial nous a donné une fessée serbe
les deux soeurs la plus jeune
mon père s'est beaucoup saoulé il s'est mis ensemble
avec une femme qui le frappe pour avoir donné un
coups qui l'ont laissé gisant mort dans le
étage horrible les 2 moi pour ne pas tout voir
ces choses et à neuf ans de ces
ans de ma maison
comme ici chercher le pain le pain de chacun
bonne journée mais c'est comme ça que nous avons commencé
travailler avec des personnes âgées
prêt combien vous facturez pour vous
caresse que je crois déjà ceci à partir de cela
le temps pas à 13 ans j'étais dans les tacos
cheveux blonds ici donc très surprise
début 14 ans maintenant j'avais plus de données
hormones 2
la langue
maison
cette semaine à venir aujourd'hui j'avais 16 ans
ici
l'année dernière était d'avoir l'air bien différent
Au groupe
ce n'est pas moi
sur un campus ou vous voulez
Je ne pense pas qu'il l'envoie jamais dans le groupe alors
saule
güidi ses tiers et grave disponible
me dit sea bekele à table
reste à prix et disponible
le tribunal de la meilleure personne active de l'euro et
passif et sanz sanz conte euro mais en
une orbite complète
pour le bébé
votre personne demande du stress
Josh Youtube
Normalement, la demande alimentaire de
centimètre de large appétissant
[Musique]
et
parfois on naît avec ça pas toujours
depuis que je suis enfant je pense que ça ne revient pas
travesti c'est parce que depuis qu'elle est toute petite elle se sent
celui qui doit être une femme
depuis l'enfance on a cet instinct je suis
un travesti je me sens totalement
fiers de ce dont ils sont fiers
tout ce dont nous avons besoin, c'est que nous
comprendre qu'ils veulent que nous apprenions à
connaître cette réalité de nous
cette magie cette magie que nous décrivons
nous quand on se maquille et quand on enlève
l'autre moi que nous avons à l'intérieur de la personne
c'est à l'intérieur qui veut toujours sortir
qu'elle est forte qu'elle est belle qu'elle veut
imposer qu'elle se sente vivante que le
nous nous enfermons plusieurs fois de peur de
la société et par peur du
discrimination et il y a beaucoup de gens
beaucoup de jeunes qui ne déclarent pas leur
véritable intérieur pour cette peur de
la société ne s'ouvrent pas et qui se vivent
frustrés toute leur vie parce qu'ils se marient
s'ils veulent aller voir l'homme marié qu'ils ont
enfants et ne pas vouloir en avoir
ils ont une femme sans vouloir avoir
femme j'ai mes complexes pas moi depuis
fille toujours j'ai toujours vu les modèles
et ça et j'ai toujours voulu être une femme
Alors, que dois-je faire avec le médium?
maquillage que j'essaie d'effacer en tout
la
choses masculines deux des traits
les plus courants que j'ai et je les transmets à
féminin
tout va mal très mal je le grec
[Musique]
je vais m'habiller, j'arrive
Et la chaleur
[Musique]
Oui
Il leur suffit d'uriner et tout mais comme le
de l'essence
mais pas assis
me sens comme un fou et maintenant nous allons au
le travail a dit pas de chance les choses qui arrivent
à la retraite
Ce sont de petites choses qui
ils passent dans la routine nous l'onglet
haut avec le froid était le froid
Bienvenue
bienvenue dans mon péché
et
comment pas
confiance
tu es ico
saveur
un dangereux
nous allons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de clients variés toutes races
de toutes les couleurs jeune bien 4
maintenant beaucoup plus la jeunesse maintenant que
vient
les gens gentils viennent les gens lourds viennent
Des gens macabres arrivent, c'est dangereux, mais
le même chemin qu'il faut suivre
écoutez ce contexte écoutez ici quand
l'un paye le visage de l'autre
ils paient bien je n'ai pas pu
nous avons besoin de cette nuit de succès et
réparer un jeu de pression 100 et vous
tombeau blesse david le second gelé
plasma
[Musique]
seuls les camions vous ne travaillez pas ici
filles sur pieds ou quoi que ce soit et c'est le
l'environnement que les clients passent ici et
tout le monde ici vient chercher la question
combien facture-t-elle quand les autres frais
vous ne comprenez pas dépend si l'on
aimé quelque chose
les filles nouvelles venues comme elles ne le font pas
ont le droit de faire diaz pour
choses antiques disons les vôtres
nous sommes ici depuis 20 ans et
toujours à paris ou nous même est un
règlement entre nous antiquité
c'est respecter deux paires cinq mille euros
côtes d'échec et est dans ma place
jour où je viens d'arriver
ou vous êtes des femmes allez sur les places de
les femmes ici qui parlent de toi entrent
carré derrière les transsexuels parce qu'ils
direct par carré disons que le
Les Argentins sont des Argentins honnêtes
mais pas dans les salles péruviennes
Colombien où le colombien et ainsi de suite
au pub ils font l'amour
canular non seulement à travers le
désagrégation thulium condition c'est quoi
qui nous donne la loi et si en 2007 danois
avec peu de monde le cinéma bouge
de polo qui de l'alignement de quoi
même
plus vieux que la fin
Je travaillais déjà à pied d'autres filles
ici d'autres personnes là-bas et ici
nous venions le garçon en train de tirer et
autres choses
et ils savaient que vanessa campo était était
ici et qu'il allait courir parce que tout le monde
nous avons couru pour celui que tout était
attendre là d'ici et jusqu'à ce que nous avancions
les garçons l'attendent
Ils l'ont attrapée par derrière, lui ont tranché la gorge et
un autre pin a mis un pour un coup dans le
tête et ils l'ont laissée ici
traîner, elle ne s'appelait pas la
la police va apprendre la concentration
Eh bien, nous avons tout mis en place même s'ils l'ont tuée
fille ici et la police oups oups oups il
Je n'ai jamais rien fait dont nous étions fatigués de dire
les voleurs sont là je ne sais pas
ils sont allés dans la forêt les voleurs sont
au-delà, ils les ont soumis pour la forêt
toujours de la discrimination de la part des
même police alors nous sommes dans le
premier monde où nous sommes
c'est une des filles qui travaille
ici qui plusieurs fois a déjà subi son
vrai avec les garçons ici qui
ils cassent le verre ils l'ont battue plusieurs fois
Parfois, elle a été battue, c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
battu plusieurs fois l'a montré
heureux qu'ils aient poignardé julián
sur les jambes regarde les choses qui
C'est vrai, on souffre beaucoup ici
car si la prostitution était légale
tout ça je pense que tout ça pas
arriverait si le gouvernement exactement
Cela nous aiderait un peu plus à nous établir comme
personne parce que c'est pour nous un
travail normal disons que l'on fait très
tort à quelqu'un ou à quoi que ce soit aucun d'entre nous
nous forçons le client à venir ici
alors le client doit être dans votre
libre de sortir avec nous ou pas
nous ne pouvons rien faire d'autre que nous n'étudions pas
faire autre chose c'était à nous
notre pain quotidien la rue que nous
a donné ça alors comment vont-ils nous faire sortir
ce que devons-nous vivre
parce que nous ne savons pas faire un autre travail
ou pas clair
et c'est là que ça marche
là j'ai déjà changé
le client est servi ici le client est servi
Salut
ici le client est servi que les gens
ne vois pas tout ce qui est privé est servi
servir des préservatifs en papier
lubrifiants toute la protection qui
plus important de ne pas protéger le client et
protéger et se protéger on met le
nous avons les préservatifs
[Musique]
au travail
c'était bien
[Musique]
intello
les plus célèbres et les lois
[des rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
priez pour que j'aille bien et non
Rien de mal ne m'arrive que les gens ne me fassent pas
mauvaises choses ou vous savez que vous sortez de votre
à la maison mais tu ne sais pas si tu vas revenir
la lampe de poche pour
vous quittez le client parce qu'il l'amène et regarde
la forêt
l'un d'eux est entré pour enseigner le
client qui
ré
jolie
et là tu te sens physiquement attiré par
une sorte de chimie oui je suis humain
Non, mais c'est mon métier et je ne devrais pas
être
je ne devrais pas
s'impliquer avec les clients mais oui
il y en a beaucoup 20 très mignons
mais je suis tombé amoureux plusieurs fois
retardé mais mais l'amour n'est pas pour
on s'aime on s'aime pas
au milieu de ce travail je pense que
pas d'amour
[Musique]
au milieu de ce travail il n'y a pas d'amour
Oh
[Musique]